yeah okay yeah I mean my music interest
is the same as like my interest outside
of playing music and and and and
consuming it it's so varied because I
like doing all kinds of things in
Aquarius yeah cuz I'm a weirdo and I
like doing everything there's an eagle
flying such a good sign it's a great
sign uh so I grew up on old church music
and like old standards like not even
like gospel kind they're like very like
recall this like like hymnal kind of
yeah musica my family was very
conservative we weren't really allowed
to listen to pop radio we went listening
to mainstream music however I was
allowed to listen to like music from the
sixties and seventies curated my dad was
a big music buff in his own way and and
really enjoyed everything from jazz to
rag times to like like Andy Andy
Williams kind of stuff like like like
old white guy music you know like he was
really into that stuff but so I was
really uh I was really and Peter Paul
and Mary and that kind of stuff but not
so much like say Simon and Garfunkel or
even the Beatles really he was just more
into like that that older fifties and
sixties stuff so I listened to a lot of
that growing up and by the time I was a
teenager I mean I was playing classical
music on the piano I started playing
piano I was 6 years old and I started to
I mean it was all classical stuff cause
they really want me to hammer in that
classical music and I could play it I
was allowed to play a little bit of jazz
but not too much you know there was
anything secular was just a little you
know or that was too mainstream was sort
of a red flag for them interesting
sounds like history no we didn't
actually we both have a lot of fire in
us through
like screw that [ __ ] I'm out yeah and
then yeah when I was a teenager it sort
of became I had a radio like a little
plastic Radio Shack radio that I hid
underneath my bed and with like those
you know the those standardized like
headphones that you'd get anybody stuck
in your hair and like he's never
comfortable I was horrible you just flat
on your ears yeah yeah so I had that
setup and I would at nighttime I would
um I would listen to pop radio and I'd
also listen to love line oh yeah how old
are you 34 you remember love line yeah
Adam Carolla dr. drew that's right
that's real idea it was his late night
yeah weird rude he started it though
right yep yeah
oh no but I learned about using condoms
because I will say that the sex ed in
being homeschooled was pretty limited
I'll just in a house that restricted
your music they probably weren't talking
about sex not not in a way that you know
I would consider healthy you know at
this time specifically absolutely so
[Music]
you